receive the bracelets of sincerity and
wisdom token of the Lord's protection
embracing you on every side
the Rope Royal is now brought
made for the coronation of King George
IV in 1821.
it is supposed to represent the four
corners of the world
and to enfold the king
with wisdom
and
righteousness
and to be the Garment of salvation
first of all
the stole is placed on by the Prince of
Wales
still with the plant badges the United
Kingdom
and also the eagle
which is also on the robe
the clasp will be connected
at the chest of the King by his son the
Prince of Wales
receive this Rome
may the Lord clothe you with the robe of
righteousness and with the garments of
salvation
the Archbishop of armor and primate of
all Ireland and Metropolitan
will now bring the orb
to the Archbishop who will place it in
the king's right hand
it represents the cosmos
and Christ's Dominion
receive this all set under the cross
and remember always that the kingdoms of
this world are become the kingdom of our
God and of his Christ
the ring will be brought from the altar
by the right honorable Lord Patel
the king will touch the ring
receive this ring
symbols of kingly dignity and a sign of
the Covenant sworn this day between God
and King
King and people
the king will now be invested
with two scepters
one of power and one of Mercy but before
that
for his right hand that will take the
scepter of kingly power a glove to
remind him to be gentle
in the use of power
receive this glove that you may hold
Authority with gentleness and Grace
trusting not in your own power but in
the mercy of God
the scepter of kingly power is placed
into the king's right hand
received the Royal scepter the end sign
of kingly power and justice
and the scepter
of mercy and the Raj of equity and mercy
are symbol of Covenant and peace
May the spirit of the Lord who anointed
Jesus at his baptism so anoint you this
day that you might exercise Authority
with wisdom and direct your counsels
with grace that by your service and
Ministry to all your people
Justice and mercy may be seen in all the
Earth
everyone will now start as we approach
the moment of crowning with Saint
Edward's crime
king of kings and Lord of lords bless we
beseech thee this crown
and so sanctify thy servant Charles upon
whose head this day thou Dost place it
for a sign of Royal Majesty that he may
be crowned with thy gracious favor and
filled with abundant grace and all
princely virtues
through him who liveth and reigneth
Supreme Over All Things One God World
Without End
amen
thank you
God saved the king
and the guns have fired here in London
and at all the saluting stations around
the kingdom and at Sea God saved the
king
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
the Archbishop of York will lead the
blessings and prayers over the new
lecron king and
Bishops and the cotton
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign